- We're back and last year,
I met an extraordinary
woman giving help and hope
to countless unhoused men and women,
living here in Los Angeles.
Not only does she personally make meals
to feed people along Skid Row,
she's rallied an army of
volunteers to help out.
And that's just one
piece of what she does.
Let's look back at my time with Jackie,
also known as the Brown Bag Lady.
(swooshing)
- I'm proud to say that
everything we do is from scratch
and we just make meals every week.
And it just, we have not missed a Sunday
and that's just amazing to me.
We give out free haircuts,
we give out clothes,
gently used shoes.
And so, it's just a group of us.
We literally get together every weekend,
we go through everything, we
put it by size, male, female.
And in addition to the
meal, we give you clothes,
sanitary items for the ladies.
And so, that's why we
came up with the logo,
"Feeding the body, nourishing the soul".
It's not just a meal.
(audience applauds)
- I love that.
Jackie's compassionate work,
landed her a hefty, $50,000,
overachievers grant from Pilot pen,
which has only helped her do even more.
We have her with us right now.
It's great to finally meet you in person.
(audience applauds)
- Nice to meet you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Thank you for having me.
- [Kelly] Oh, my God, I'm
so excited you're here.
And you must've been
thrilled to get the grant.
- Oh my gosh, my sister's
friend nominated me.
I was standing in the reception area
of the law office, where I work
and the guy on the other
end of the phone says,
"Jacqueline Norvell, you
are the grand prize winner
of the Pilot pen, G2
overachiever, $50,000 grant".
(Jackie gasps)
Oh, it was so exciting.
I still get chills when I think about it.
I mean, the wonderful
Pilot pen team picked me up
and presented me with
a cheque for $50,000.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
(audience applauds)
- It was awesome.
- [Kelly] What'd you end up
getting to do with the money?
- Oh my goodness, so,
we were doing everything
out of my 2005, Nissan, Pathfinder.
So we were able to buy a van.
- [Kelly] Oh, good.
- And we bought a van
and we have men's clothes on one side
and women's clothes on the other side,
we have hygiene products,
full toiletries for the men,
we have shoes, we have socks.
We just totally load the van up.
And then it was also great,
because every year we take backpacks
to an underserved school and we fill them.
It's not just a backpack.
We get together and we fill
it with school supplies.
- Because that's expensive and
families can't afford that.
- They can't, they cannot.
And it's just been, you know, phenomenal.
And we buy the backpacks,
it's not like I'm point and click.
I literally go to a warehouse,
because what a pre-k child wants,
a fifth grader does not want.
So, they're tailored to the,
you know, to each grade and...
- [Kelly] You're investing in them.
- Yes, yes.
- Yeah and people do better with that.
Kids that know that people care
and give them something
like that, they work harder.
- [Jackie] Yes.
- And they, they want to pay it forward
and invest in others as well,
it's a great domino effect.
- It is.
- So, and now you've taken
on a new, ambitious project.
So what's this?
- Oh my gosh.
Okay so, in dealing and
talking and chatting,
because you know, the
homeless become your friend,
you see them every weekend,
you talk with them,
you know their background.
I realize that a lot were
in the foster care system
and had been separated from
their brother and sister.
I just assumed,
you have a brother and
sister, you go together.
No, the sister could go,
say in San Bernardino
and the brother is, you
know, in Orange County
and they get to see each other
once a month, for one hour.
And then it starts the downward spiral.
- Oh wow.
- [Jackie] So, what we
are committed to doing,
and we are going to do it.
We are going to...
I'm sorry.
- [Kelly] No, oh my gosh.
It's an amazing thing that you're doing
and it should touch you.
- We are going to reunite
siblings that have been separated.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- By the system.
And no matter where they are,
no matter where they're at,
we're gonna bring them together
for one week of sleep away
camp and I'm so excited.
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
(audience applauds)
Oh my gosh.
- Yes.
- Here, here, here, here.
- I'm so excited.
(audience applauds)
- Well all right, well, good news,
our season long partner, Pilot pen
is looking for the next $100,000,
G2 overachievers grant winner.
And they want to recognize
one, exceptional individual,
who goes above and beyond
their everyday responsibilities
to improve the lives of
others, like you have.
And this $100,000 grant will
greatly expand their reach
to communities in need,
but that's not all,
Pilot also wants to celebrate exceptional,
young scholars with a $15,000,
G2 overachievers student grant,
which is... That creates
so much opportunity,
which is a beautiful thing.
This will recognize young
people, 13 to 19 years old,
who are excelling in their studies
and making a real
difference in other's lives
outside the classroom.
If you know, a remarkable
person going above and beyond
to improve their community,
please submit a handwritten
nomination, right now.
Let's do it.
The deadline for the $100,000,
G2 overachievers grant
is January 15th, 2022.
And the deadline for the
$15,000, student grant
is right around the corner,
November 15th, 2021.
So, get on it.
Go to G2overachievers.com to learn more.
Thank you so much.
(audience applauds)
- [Jackie] Absolutely.
- And I want us to keep in contact,
helping out with what you're doing.
- For sure.
- [Kelly] It's such a cool thing.
- Thank you, thank you.
- [Kelly] And it's important,
especially for those foster kids.
- Thank you for shining light.
I really appreciate you shining
light on our non-profit.